well one thing was clear about the
election we know who the losers are
the pollsters and the media the cannibal
twins who feed off each other's
manufactured delusions
and make a neat profit off them it works
like this
for nearly half a decade the media
labels a candidate and by extension his
supporters
as racist that silences those voters so
the polls reflect a false picture
i mean why would you tell the truth to
strangers if that truth is deemed
socially unacceptable
meanwhile riots ensue as another
consequence of that smear
as though america deserves it under
trump yet even though they stuck the
evil white man tag on trump his
popularity left in this election among
latinos
black men and black women again if
trump's racist
man he sucks at it he's no joy reid
if somehow they managed to stumble into
the supreme court
do any of you guys trust uncle clarence
and amy coney barrett and those guys to
actually
follow the letter of the law no wow
so there was that well it should piss
you off trump is
racist was the tentpole hoax where every
other hateful smear found its shade
imagine how many more blacks latinos and
yes whites would have voted for trump if
an honest media had took an
axe to that poll which is why they
didn't
speaking of polls you wonder why no one
trusts this outcome including trump
when you keep being lied to how can you
trust anyone no wonder pollsters never
ask if you trust polls
how can you go to bed seeing one result
then wake up to a new one that saves the
day for the media's choice
and not be a little suspicious so don't
blame trump
blame the media pollster industrial
complex
i compare them to snake oil salesmen but
that's unkind to snakes and
salesmen because whatever the media's
pollsters are selling
nobody's going to buy it ever again
i said that by the way in 2016 jesse so
i was wrong
then um if people in normal jobs were as
wrong as the media and pollsters
they would be out of a job jesse yeah
but i think you're going to go in four
more years you're going to get cooked
polls
there's no accountability in that
industry they've been wrong a lot and
they never changed their internal
sampling
they were even more wrong in 2020 than
they were in 2012 because
trust me um when you have a poll
designed to depress trump supporters
because you put
a sample of 49 democrats into that poll
the president's never going to do well
in a poll that's half sampled with
democrats
so that's designed to think you know
you're in wisconsin and you see a poll
and abc news washington post there i
said it
had donald trump losing by 17 points
so you say to yourself why do i even
need to vote i mean it's a foregone
conclusion
and it's sad and it's not just the
polling industry it's the media industry
at large
this was going to be a landslide victory
what is it a
nine or ten percent national election no
it was two to three percent so again
they got the last two elections wrong
they got coronavirus wrong the russia
hoax and then they covered up for the
big guy
right at the home stretch you don't know
what kind of damage that did but
we'll never find out dana if if
posters put are putting their thumb on
the scale are they doing it by accident
that they don't even know they're doing
it
i look forward to the autopsy
of that or a sick woman
we have to kill them first you know i
like data
i like to look at the science like the
social sciences that we have
does it need to be revisited perhaps i
mean do they have half a c
50 49 democrats because there's that
many democrats
in the district i don't know there's a i
think it has
a lot of improvement to do but i also
think that everybody keep in mind
look at the average don't just take one
poll like take the look at the average
and if you look at tom bevin
um he runs real clear politics for
example pennsylvania
they had it uh one uh one point up for
biden at the end
the night before but the only reason
that came in was because of the last
week you put in insider advantage you
put in susquehanna and you put in
trafalgar
and that really narrows the gap well
well again that's why
i was you know i try to look at the
average and i don't think that this
outcome is
that entirely unbelievable at this point
but i do think also the other thing
about the media is
there was this like rumor that
disinformation was the reason
that president trump was winning in
miami-dade county not the fact that
he had actually worked his tail off and
yet you had latinos for trump
and cubans for trump who are down there
and al sharpton said
that cuban americans are susceptible to
propaganda about socialism
well why do you think that might be
because they fled socialism yeah and new
york was susceptible to tawanna brawley
propaganda
uh juan what do you make of the fact of
the shy voter syndrome is there any way
pollsters can figure that out
well sure i mean look i i don't think
that there were necessarily so many shy
i think you had people who weren't
necessarily part of the voter pool
before who might have come out i think
he might have drawn out some new people
we set a record in terms of voter
turnout yesterday
but that's for republicans and democrats
it was amazing how many people voted
yesterday
it's good news but look i to your point
i think obviously there was no blue wave
and you saw some of the posters saying
that that was going to be a possibility
it didn't happen
but you know in general i have to agree
with dana perino i think that
if you look at 2018 they were on target
and saying there was going to be a blue
wave and there was a blue wave in 2018.
there always is
in that but not in every time but i just
want to say you know i also think
how come you guys aren't talking about
like the people i talked to the people
on the house republican side they
thought
house republicans were going to have a
bad night senate you know that's the
next block but i know but i'm just
saying
you listened to president trump he said
we're going to win the house we're going
to win the senate we're going to win win
win
he was predicting that it didn't happen
well i think they kept the senate didn't
they
no he was predicting they would keep the
house martha
i'm talking about the senate you know i
i think that michael moore is probably
the best pollster around
i agree because michael moore said look
take the number
cut it in half absolutely right maybe go
down another point he has had a pretty
good
read on the way things are going and the
other thing that we see in this is that
when you look at the popular voice look
at how
very very close this is it's time for
both sides to wake up and realize the
reality
of the other side and that there's you
know half of america
very supportive of president trump very
supportive of his policies for a number
of reasons and i think that
the media and the pollsters need to wake
up and figure out a way
to reach these people no one is going to
pay any attention to them the next time
around they need to completely
regroup you're right or just hire
michael moore as your pollster because
he's never been wrong